what i thought was was interesting about
you know the dilemma of trying to
explain to people that this is a this is
a wonderful field driven by people who
are generous and and care about what
they do and there are dealers who
believed fervently in the work that
they're artists that they represent make
if the bottom dropped out of the market
and the art of the artist is not going
to sell anything he or she will keep
working and the dealer will keep trying
to find some way to convince somebody to
buy the stuff you don't see people who
roared through huge amounts of money and
bear stearns offering you know to go
back and work at bear stearns for free
for the next couple of years to get the
firm back on its feet again they're not
going to show up and go to work unless
they're being paid and how anybody could
think that that that that people in the
stock market had more integrity than
people in the art world especially at a
time like like this with these
charlatans of these shysters and these
thieves and liars you know the people
who have committed themselves in their
whole lives and all their and and given
up so much to do it sacrifice so much to
do it women have decided not to have
children because they don't think that
they can really do both well one of the
most major sacrifices someone could make
so i only have so much time and energy
and money and i'm going to put it into
my work or someone else who's you know
willing to make a vow of poverty you
know to keep to keep working how they
can become
paired to the Bernie Madoff's in the
world and be found wanting and for them
to be the ones who are without integrity
is beyond me